Ce n’est pas très frais. Je vais rajouter
quelques glaçons, ce sera mieux!
C’est étonnant, quand j’ai mis
le bac à glaçons au congélateur,
les cubes n’étaient
pas tout à fait pleins
et là, ça déborde !
C'est ce que les scientifiques appellent :
une anomalie
«dilatomètrique».
Je sais, ça jette un froid
- elle est facile celle-là-
mais pas de panique!
En général, quand un corps passe
de l’état liquide à l’état solide,
son volume diminue.
Les molécules qui le composent,
agitées et désordonnées
quand la matière
se présente à l’état liquide,
se ré-agencent et occupent un volume moins grand
quand elles passent à l’état solide.
Comme si tout le monde reprenait sa place.
C'est le cas des métaux notamment,
du fer ou de l’acier.
Sous l’effet de la chaleur,
la matière se ramollit,
finit par se liquéfier, opération pendant laquelle
le métal prend du volume
avant de se rétracter
quand il se refroidit.
Ce phénomène a pendant longtemps été utilisé
pour assembler des pièces métalliques.
C’est le cas des 18 000 éléments
qui composent la tour Eiffel
et qui ont été assemblés
grâce à des rivets.
Des clous chauffés à blanc.
Glissés dans des trous aménagés dans les pièces,
dont on peut écraser la pointe,
étant donné que le clou à été chauffé à blanc
et que la matière est devenue plus ductile.
En refroidissant, le métal se contracte et le rivet serre
les deux pièces métalliques l’une contre l’autre.
Alors, ce type de rivets n’est plus utilisé
depuis très longtemps,
ils ont été remplacés
par des vis et des écrous.
Enfin... je vous raconte tout ça,
juste pour vous rafraîchir la mémoire,
parce qu’en fait, on est là
pour parler de glaçons.
Pourquoi occupent-ils
davantage de volume que l’eau liquide ?
C’est à cause de la structure
de la molécule d’eau H2O:
un atome d’oxygène auquel sont liés
deux atomes d’hydrogène.
Ces atomes possèdent une charge électrique.
Négative pour l’oxygène, positive pour l’hydrogène.
Concrètement, ces atomes s’attirent
les uns, les autres.
Du coup, les molécules d’eau s’attirent
les unes, les autres.
En physique, on parle de
"liaison hydrogène".
Ces liaisons existent bien
quand l’eau est liquide.
Mais les molécules sont tellement agitées
qu’elles sont complètement tordues.
Les liaisons,
hein !
À l’inverse, quand la température passe
en dessous de 0°C, tout se fige.
Les molécules sont
beaucoup moins agitées.
Elles se lient les unes aux autres
en formant des hexagones
qui occupent davantage d’espace
que le chaos précédent.
Ça va? Ça ne chauffe pas trop?
Alors on peut continuer.
Et on va faire plus léger,
au sens propre du terme.
A cause de cette particularité
physico-chimique,
la glace est moins dense que l'eau liquide,
sa masse volumique est moins élevée.
Tenez, comparons
ces deux bocaux.
Ils contiennent tous les deux un litre.
Un litre de glace et un litre d’eau liquide.
Un litre de glace
a une masse de 910 grammes
alors qu’un litre d’eau
a une masse de 1000 grammes.
On peut aussi prendre les choses
dans l’autre sens:
à masse égale, la glace occupe
un plus grand volume que l’eau liquide.
C’est pour cette raison que
la glace flotte à la surface de l’eau.
Et c’est aussi pour cette raison que
l’eau ne déborde pas quand le glaçon fond.
En fait, le volume du glaçon immergé
correspond exactement
au volume d’eau obtenu
lorsque le glaçon aura totalement fondu.
Qui a inventé
la machine à glaçons?
Plusieurs noms circulent
dont celui d’un Français: Ferdinand Carré.
Et ce n’est pas pour cette raison que
les premiers glaçons avaient une forme de cube!
Une vraie tête de premier de la glace,
vous ne trouvez pas?
Il présente sa machine à
l’Exposition Universelle de Londres en 1862.
Elle produit des pains de glace
qui sont ensuite débités à la vente.
Evidemment, il faut
un peu de place pour la loger.
Il faut attendre le début du XXè siècle
pour qu’apparaissent
les premières
machines domestiques.
Et ce n’est qu’au début
des années 1950
que les ménages s’équipent de réfrigérateurs
munis d’un compartiment freezer.
Encore un peu d’Histoire…
Avant la machine de Ferdinand Carré,
il fallait aller chercher la glace
sur les glaciers des montagnes ou
la récupérer l’hiver sur les cours d’eau gelée.
Le nom de cette station du métro parisien
rappelle cette activité.
Autrefois, le quartier était traversé par une rivière,
la Bièvre, qui est aujourd’hui enterrée.
L’hiver, on récupérait la glace et on la stockait
dans des puits qu’on appelait des "glacières".
Ce qui permettait de conserver la glace
et d'en avoir pendant tout l’été.
Bon!
Faut pas que je traîne…
Bon il était temps que ça se termine,
ça fond vite la glace.
Jeffrey !
ramène-nous des glaçons.
À très bientôt
et surtout n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes déconfinés,
mais on reste en lien!
Quand j'ai mis le bac à glaçons
au congélateur,
les cubes n'étaient pas tout à la fait...
tout à la fait plein.
Des pains de glace
qui sont ensuite débit...